robert molars russia investigation has
found very little evidence of the
russian collusion that's supposedly
justified it it has though accidentally
exposed a lot of political bias in the
federal government now some of Donald
Trump's campaign team say they're
considering a lawsuit Michael Caputo
advised Trump's presidential campaign
and he joins us tonight Michael thanks
for coming up thanks for having me
Tucker it's a pleasure to be here again
let me do diligence and ask you the
obvious question during your time
serving the Trump campaign did you see
any behavior that suggested collusion or
inappropriate contact with the Russian
government I know I did not in fact I'll
tell you exactly what I told the House
Intelligence Committee in July I saw no
Russian collusion I heard no talk of
Russia no one ever asked me about the
years that I lived in Russia the whole
time I was in Trump Tower and we didn't
use Russian dressing this whole thing is
a bogus investigation jinda because
Hillary Clinton needs an excuse for
forgetting to go to Michigan and
Wisconsin and my family gets to pay for
it all the legal fees to testify before
Congress probably four times saying the
same thing four times over to three
different bodies because Congress can't
talk to each other how much have you had
to pay personally to respond to this
well right now I've only got one hearing
under my belt
I've got Senate Intelligence wants me
for two hearings and now we hear from
Dianne Feinstein that she wants me at
the Senate Judiciary each one of those
hearings can be thirty thousand dollars
so I'm thirty thousand down now and in
the end I'll end up paying legal fees
that equal more than I make it a year
that's horrifying what are you buying
and you know what I've got kids to raise
you know I've got I mean I live in
flyover country Tucker I live in Buffalo
we don't make Washington money or New
York money and all you know this smear
first ask questions later mentality of
Washington is destroying not just my
family but a lot of families on totally
ridiculous grounds Russian agents it's
absurd what what do you make of
apparently what the memo says that the
Obama administration you
allegations of collusion with Russia in
order to justify surveillance of the
Trump campaign you know I listened to
what you said as we led up to this
segment and I'm just disgusted by it but
I got to tell you I completely expected
it I've been looking forward to this
memo coming out ever since I heard it
heard of it
thank God for chairman Nunez thank God
for him he's endured so much you know
vitriol and insults from the left trying
to stop him in in this effort I'll tell
you here's the bottom line Tucker
I mean Barack Obama weaponized the
Department of Justice Barack Obama
politicized the FBI the FBI
it's our nation's premier and Criminal
Investigation organization I know a lot
of rank-and-file an FBI members and
they're all embarrassed about this the
DOJ completely weaponized we saw it go
down with the IRS as well we saw how the
the weaponized Department of Justice
went after people like congressman
Michael Grimm and and you know Dinesh
D'Souza and many others this has really
been it's been on its way to happening
for quite some time and we're at the
most politicized level of our DOJ and
FBI that in my lifetime it's god of it
sure seems that way so I don't know if
you can respond to this final question
because you're the subject of a lot of
attention but Carter page
he was the pretext for apparently a lot
of this spying on the Trump campaign
I've just only seen him on it during his
MSNBC interviews he doesn't look to me
like a very credible Russian agent did
you ever see any indication that he was
speaking to the Russians that he was
speaking in Russian at a shortwave radio
in his attic I mean was there anything
about Carter page that made you think he
was a mole no in fact we never saw
Carter page in Trump Tower he was like
George papadopolis a member of a rarely
meeting policy committee volunteers who
would come in for one meeting a month
I mean Carter page I mean he's legit you
know a knows about Russia people in
Russia know him he was in business there
and I see him on television I see him
walking away from these inquiries on the
hill I gotta tell you first I was kind
of you know palms up about the guy but
now I feel really bad for him
now what I'm hearing about this memo I
feel really angry for him well he said
today to one of our producers here at
Fox News that he welcomes the release
them oh I bet he does but and I'll tell
you what if anybody needs to get some
justice out of this it's guys like
Carter Paige I agree I think he's been
shafted great to see you tonight thank
you thanks doctor